oh yeah Bojack you ever meet any Boston
celebrities one time at Bristol Farms
Ben Affleck and I did reach for the same
bunch of grapes oh he hates grapes just
like us
hey mom Ben Affleck eats grapes bulchek
said he fed Affleck grapes
he was griping it up with the daredevil
himself is this a greatest day of my
life oh hey I don't suppose you boys
would have any interest in maybe playing
some touch football later ooh you know
what else we gotta do we gotta watch the
cry add video that sounds good what's
that no we don't need to revisit that
when didi was 16 we made up a secret pen
pal for her name Leo we all took turns
writing ìletís pretended to be the
sensitive boy from Cambridge what after
six months of letters we hide a homeless
guy to pretend to be leo and taken to
the homecoming dance that's a good prank
I was humiliated yeah you want to get it
it's a brother thing right brothers
laugh about this yep my therapist thinks
the same thing I'm gonna go meet with
the funeral director any of you boys
want to come nah I ain't so big on
funeral homes DeeDee all them dead
bodies they give me the jeebies yeah
DeeDee why do we got to go fine
none of you have to go I'll take care of
everything Thank You Diane we all really
appreciate it
come on Bo Jack well you gotta take Bo
Jack with you
Oh boys you have stolen my heart like
Dave Roberts stole second base I must go
now but I'll see you all at the funeral
okay and when I do you're all getting
noogies tell me about your father well
he was a mean sadistic alcoholic who
never supported anything I did and
actively delighted in seeing me fail hmm
I see sounds like you're looking for our
piece of
dad package that would be too good for
my father might I then suggest our piece
of dad package would be too good
for him package yeah that's the one
[Music]